- [Yoko] Whether it's taking the subway,
(man speaking in foreign language)
- [Yoko] Shopping for groceries.
(machine speaking in foreign language)
- Or going into the office,
to do pretty much anything
in Beijing these days,
you're required to show this,
a negative COVID-19 test result
within the past 72 hours.
So thousands of PCR testing booths
have popped up in Beijing
and other major cities across the country.
(Mi speaking in foreign language)
- The goal?
To test people regularly in
order to spot the virus quickly
before it spreads.
Plus, Beijing is back on high alert
as case numbers jumped in mid-June,
despite the rollout of
thousands of swabbing booths.
Beijing has been building
and staffing many of these testing sites
and that raises concerns
about whether the strategy
is financially sustainable and effective
at stamping out the virus.
Here's a testing booth.
I walked around in this
area for about five minutes
and already found about
five testing booths,
and on this Chinese map app,
you can also find testing locations.
In the three kilometers' distance,
you can see that there
are one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight
PCR test centers around me.
(Yoko speaking in foreign language)
I just took a free PCR test as required
by the Beijing government
but making sure that everyone
gets tested frequently
and for free comes with a cost.
The city government hasn't revealed
how much money has gone
into testing its population
of more than 21 million people
but based on the price set
by the central government
of about $1.20 per test,
it would cost more than $25 million a day
to cover all of the
residents in the capital.
Authorities have started rolling
out regular testing sites
in cities with high risks.
But economists estimate
that if the whole country
were to adopt Beijing's
72-hour testing requirement,
it would cost up to 1.7% of the GDP.
For comparison, China's
entire healthcare budget
in 2020 was about 7% of the GDP.
And building a city-wide
network of testing sites
also requires investments in
staffing and construction.
Many of the booths that I saw in Beijing
had at least two people working in it,
and according to Chinese state media,
there are more than 9,000 booths like this
here in the capital.
Some private companies
that operate some locations
are offering a monthly
salary of more $1,500.
These stations also vary in quality.
Some are made up of a few
folding chairs and tables
under a canopy,
while others are more
solid structures outfitted
with plastic barriers,
gloves and air conditioners.
All these booths tell
us that China's sticking
to its zero-COVID policy,
which is a approach
that's becoming rare
elsewhere in the world.
Some analysts say China's
strategy of frequent testing
may be able to reduce some economic costs
by preventing city-wide lockdowns
but this approach can also
become a financial burden
for the government in the long run.
China's top health authority
said it's necessary
to provide fast and high-quality
PCR testing services
in order to prevent the
virus from spreading widely.
Still, it also said that
not every city needs
to do that many tests.
(He speaking in foreign language)
- There are also questions
about the effectiveness of
requiring regular testing,
especially if some security guards
at entrances of public places
don't check the results closely
or some people just avoid
getting tested at all.
China's approach means
that such frequent testing
and partial lockdowns
are going to be a part of people's lives
for the foreseeable future,
and that's a burden on the people,
especially as they start to realize
that the rest of the world has moved on
from such strict restrictions.
(dramatic music)